Show me the one who's safety deemed such destruction.
This is the one. The one that you
hunted then saved?
Yes.
The one that saved me as well.
From the Mudhorn?
Yes.
It looks helpless.
It's injured but
it is not helpless.
It's species can move
objects with its mind.
I know of such
things.
The songs of eons past of battles
between Mandalore the Great and an order of sorcerers called Jedi that
fought with such powers.
It is an enemy?
No, its kind were enemies. But this
But this individual is not.
What is it?
It is a foundling.
By Creed it is in your care.
You wish me
to train this thing? It's too weak, it
would die. You have no choice, you must
reunite it with its own kind.
Where?
This you must determine.
You're expecting me to search the galaxy for the home of this
creature and deliver it to a race of
enemy sorcerers?
This is the way.
Welcome back everyone its Charlie Happy
New Year this is going to be my new
Mandalorian season 2 video and talking
about the ancient Jedi Mandalorian Wars
and why they're referencing them so
heavily during this scene here it's all
connected to stuff that they're trying
to seed and world build within the Star
Wars universe because the next Star Wars movie is supposed to be set during the
past also reference that during the
video too because there's been some news
about that if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Mandalorian videos I'll be doing bonus
videos until we get to season 2 episodes
we're doing a merch giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your predictions about
season 2 on the video so obviously
careful for spoilers for everything from
the Mandalorian season 1 because we'll
be talking about this scene and some
other things that they reference also
what's going on with the darksaber so
her line about ancient Jedi sorcerers is
the throwback line to the Knights of the
Old Republic era a great series of
multiple wars between the Mandalorian
clans and the Jedi Order and also to
that funny Han Solo reference from a new
hope when he refers to hokey religions
and ancient weapons things echoing back
thousands of years in the Star Wars
timeline that we haven't really seen in
the movies yet but do they sort of teed
up a little bit recently what does this
mean for season 2 episodes and obviously
what does this have to do with the new
Star Wars movie that was just announced
so when the Mandalorian bulks at his
mission as she gives it to him you want
me to hand him over to enemy sorcerers
she notes that they're not enemies right
now the Jedi aren't their enemies in
present-day they were a long time ago in
a galaxy far far away the actual
Mandalorian Jedi war she speaks of were
fought between 4 and 5 thousand years
ago it was started by a group of
sword-wielding Mandalorians called the
Mandalorian Crusaders and around that
time was also when the darksaber was
created so no coincidence that you see
it appear during the end of season 1
obviously it's more relevant to what's
happening in present day but they're
sort of connecting the Star Wars
timeline with all these references and
easter eggs so also no coincidence that
they referenced the Jedi Mandalorian
Wars from thousands of years ago on the
Clone Wars series when they introduced
the darksaber for the first time on
that series for generations my ancestors
fought proudly as warriors against the
Jedi
now that woman tarnishes the very name
Mandalorian this lightsaber was stolen
from your Jedi Temple by my ancestors
during the fall of the Old Republic if
you didn't watch that series that was
actually Jon Favreau's Priebe isla
character so he also played a character
during the Mandalorians season one he
just did a voiceover he wasn't
underneath that armor but the character
he was playing on the Mandalorian Sirius
was also a member of previz TLAs house
those were the Death Watch Mandalorians
on that series we also saw a live-action
version of the Death Watch Mandalorians
in the flashback they were the ones that
saved Din Djarick's Mandalorian character
when he was a child during the Clone Wars when the droids came to attack seal
it's all connected, but the Mandalorians that fought with
the Jedi were called the Mandalorian
Crusaders they wielded swords they were
actually started as an organization by
Mandalore the first the person who's
known for conquering the great mythos or
that they also referenced during the
Mandalorian episode - also connecting
these Easter eggs and references to
what's happening in the Star Wars movies, is going forward after Star Wars Episode 9,
no coincidence that they're referencing ancient Jedi Mandalorian
Wars in the series because like they
reference for ceiling on the Mandalorian
then a couple days later you see it
happen during Star Wars Episode 9
they referenced the ancient Jedi
Mandalorian Wars that thousands of years
ago they also just canonized Darth Revan
from Knights of the Old Republic during
Star Wars rise of Skywalker in the next
Star Wars movie is reportedly going to
be set during the past now not the
distant past of the Old Republic era but
the period they're calling the High
Republic era the height of the Republic
hundreds of years ago I know it sounds a
little confusing what's the difference
between the Republic the Old Republic
and the New Republic because there are
three different organizations the Old
Republic era ended around five thousand
years ago with the fall of the Old
Republic that's when the final wars
between the Mandalorians and the Jedi
started the Mandalorian Crusaders used
the fall of the Old Republic as an
opportunity to strike out in a bid to
claim most of the galaxy from the Old
Republic what followed that period was
what they call the High Republic era the
reason why they don't call it the New
Republic is because a lot of this
backstory in the concept of the hybrid
public was created after they created
the New Republic era in the comics
so they'd already used the New Republic
name to define another period in time so
they just had to come up with a
different name for it the really cool
thing about this hi Republic era movie
that they're supposedly doing is it is
going to basically be a young Yoda movie
now we talked about baby Yoda but really
he's just a member of Yoda's race it's
not an actual baby version of the Yoda
character from the original trilogy but
this new Star Wars movie is said about
400 years in the past when Yoda would
actually be quite a bit younger but
after he'd been a Jedi Master for a
couple hundred years the timeline is a
little unclear exactly when Yoda became
a Jedi Master but there been a couple
instances where he's been quoted as
saying that he's been training Jedi for
almost 800 years so it just makes it
sound like he became a Jedi Master
sometime after he turned a hundred years
old which even if you assumed that he
was a very advanced forced user as a
youngling just like baby Yoda is and it
took him way less time to become a Jedi
Master he's still trained for a number
of decades before actually becoming a
master most of the canonical Jedi
Masters that you see running around in
the movies in the series took them
between 20 and 30 years to achieve the
rank of Master obi-wan Kenobi is on the
faster end of that spectrum it took him
just a little over 20 years to achieve
the rank of Master but just to give you
a sense for Yoda's timeline in the Star Wars
universe he was born a little less
than nine hundred years before the
Battle of Yavin so he was around for
most of what you would consider this
High Republic era some of the really cool details about the Jedi Mandalorian Wars
were thousands of years ago or that
the Wars themselves were the reason why
the Mandalorians created their famous
best car armor and modern armor smithing
techniques that were so much better than
the rest of the galaxy the very
practical reason that that happened is
that at the beginning of those Wars the
Mandalorians wore regular armor and were no match for Jedi powers and weapons
then lightsabers cut through the
Mandalorian crusaders like a hot knife
through stormtrooper butter and out of
their initial failures they developed
their military customs and advanced best
car metal smithing techniques the reason
why the best car armor was so special
yes it looks very cool but practically
it was extra strong compared to normal
armor alloys it was highly effective at
resisting blaster fire and it was even
highly resistant to Jedi lightsabers you
all probably know the Mandalorians fate
ultimately they wound up losing those
Wars but in the end they had refined
their armor smithing techniques to near
perfection and since then their
traditions of armor smithing haven't
changed that much in a few thousand
years so the customs that you see the
armor Smith here practicing on the
Mandalorian series are the same
traditions in way that they created
Armour thousands and thousands of years
ago the other important reason why I
think they're introducing this much Jedi
Mandalorian lore heading into season 2
is because the Mandalorian Himself will
find more force sensitive people capable
of training baby Yoda in the force but
it'll wind up turning into another
situation like the Mandalorian Episode
three where initially he thinks he's
fulfilling the terms of his mission by
handing baby Yoda over to these new Jedi but winds up realizing that they're
going to be just as bad for him maybe
exploit him in a slightly different way
as bad as the Imperials like Moff Gideon
or Werner Herzog's character we're going
to do so the mando will be forced to make a
similar choice again is baby Yoda better
with them or is he better with me as
their relationship and their father-son
bond continues to grow papa bless
they'll make more announcements about
this young Yoda
Star Wars movie later this year there
were some people claiming Lucasfilm was
going to reveal details later in January
I don't know if that's true but if they
do all totally do a video about it
what's going to happen next though is next
month in February the new Clone Wars
season 7 episodes will be released
starting February 17th there are 12
episodes total that'll cover the siege
of Mandalore in the night of a thousand
tears that Moff Gideon referenced during
the Mandalore episode aid see how I said
everything is connected
maybe Moff Gideon will also show up
during those new Clone Wars episodes
then sometime in August Marvel's Falcon
and Winter Soldier episodes will start
the run for six weeks then they'll do
six weeks of the Wandavision series
with Scarlet Witch then by mid-november
the Mandalorian season 2 episodes will
start and they'll run through the end of
the year then because the obi-wan series
are filming their episodes this summer
they might release that right after the
Mandalorian season 2 episodes finish
I'll do more videos for everything as we
start to get more details but leave all
your requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
season 2 teaser video and learn about
the darksaber and click here for my
Marvel New Mutants trailer video
Tahnk you so much for watching everybody stay awesome!
I have spoken.